>> So, I'm curious, why is it that
males are more susceptible to sex-linked traits than females?
>> Well that actually has a lot to do with the fact that the X and the Y
don't have the same genes on them. And the
X chromosome is also much longer than the Y chromosome.
>> Does that mean the X chromosome has more genes on it?
>> It's exactly what it means. And the genes that
the X chromosome has aren't actually on the Y chromosome.
>> So is it beneficial to have two copies of the X?
>> Yeah, in a sense it is. I mean all your other
autosomes you have two copies of, right? It's kind of like having a back up
copy for a lot of the genes. In the same way that you'd have
a backup copy for data on your computer. You might have it on your
internal hard drive and then have a backup copy on an external hard drive.
>> So if one crashes, you still have the other.
>> Right but you're still not completely protected because both
of the hard drives could still crash. Although it's less likely
that both of them would crash than just one of
them. And the same is actually true for recessive alleles on
the X chromosome, in the case of males, if you
only have one copy of the X. A recessive allele is
really more of a dominant allele because there's no back
up copy to mask up the affect of the recessive allele.
>> So, for females, you could still be affected by the
trait, but if both of your X-chromosomes had that recessive allele.
>> Exactly. We can even see this in a trait like red-green
color blindness in the general population. The fact that 8% of males
have some form of red-green color blindness, while only 0.5%
of females have a similar form of red-green color blindness.
>> Well, I'm curious, are you red/green color blind?
Let us know, and are you male or a
female, so we can see how the distribution lines
up with our class, compared to the general population.